it's war ryan started it hugh jackman
here
no one likes you is just an evil person
frenemies hugh jackman and ryan reynolds
are making amends this holiday season
vowing to make the holidays a time for
forgiveness
all for good cause you forgive me
for exposing you for the monster that
you truly are
yes and to everyone but ryan please
forgive me for even engaging with
someone of his emotional maturity
okay so maybe the pair didn't quite
understand the concept of forgiveness
but what they do understand is the
concept of giving back
furthering fundraising for their
charitable organizations the laughing
man foundation and sick kids foundation
by teaming up with sam's club this
holiday when you shop at sam's club you
can side with me
and not only affirm ryan is the canned
cranberry source of human beings
but you'll also contribute to the laffy
man foundation which helps coffee
farming communities around the world
or side with me to send a message that
like mistletoe hugh just makes things
awkward
and sam's club will help me support
efforts to provide compassionate care to
sick children
through the sick kids foundation you
know what we're okay if this feud
continues especially
with a little holiday spirit so i guess
the holidays aren't about forgiveness
after all
no no as always it's an emotional brawl
with friends
loved ones also also hated ones right
yeah visit sam'sclub.com the feud